one of the things that we talk about
when using more humor effectively in the
workplace is that you want to avoid
going blue or saying anything that would
be considered offensive or a little
gross typically we suggest it's you know
avoiding topics like sex drugs and rock
and roll the question is why the word
blue well there's one theory that I find
fascinating that suggests that the
terminology for this actually came back
from pre-standup Comedy days stand up
comedy kind of got its start really
before even in the U.S back in the UK
and music calls they would have these
MCS that would host these Music Hall
events and in between the sets they
would do essentially a little bit of
material they're acting as an emcee do a
little bit of Comedy getting the
audience to laugh or joke a little bit
more now at this time the crown the
royalty had very strict rules of what
could be said and so you would have to
submit your script as the MC before you
could do this show and the kind of
theory or kind Story Goes that anything
that they didn't think you would be
allowed to say that they consider it
inappropriate or not good for the
audience they would scratch out in blue
ink and thus the material that was no
longer fit for this type of General
audience became known as blue material
if you're incorporating humor into your
work try to stick with I don't know
maybe we'll call it green humor I'm not
entirely sure but stay away from the
blue and stick with more positive
inclusive humor